hey here we are again with our daily
update it's Monday yep daily apocalyptic
like is that funny but it's like you got
a [ __ ] joke about it like what you're
Clark else are you gonna do a chilled
out just chill out
well yeah that's just that that kind of
goes for our zombies alrighty chill out
about stuff it's like it's gonna be
alright
I don't know like I remember reading
with something a long time ago I think
it was like who the guys from MST of all
people like said something about like
you know it's like everything's gonna be
okay and it's like even if it's not okay
right now like eventually it will be
like it's not okay it's still okay about
it yeah so uh I think in the next few
weeks you know people are gonna find out
that not many people were as directly
affected as they thought that there was
gonna be affected you know I mean it's
people are gonna be affected but you're
probably imagining it much worse than it
really is gonna be it's like the
difference between when you're a little
kid getting a spanking and wait it goes
way to get this fanger was worse to get
in fact you're like oh that's all that
[ __ ] was yeah okay I'm gonna do that
[ __ ] again yeah a little Tom dad defined
cuz once you get over the worst well
it's just like like I said anticipation
it's usually like either the best or the
worst Park it's like even when you're
anticipating something awesome it's
usually not as awesome and yeah yeah
like I think the best part is like
waiting for this yeah waiting to get
into the army was [ __ ] like harder
than waiting to get into the army and
going to basic training in a way it was
harder than basic training yeah cuz you
could deal with basic training on a
daily basis it was right there all you
just had to make sure you did you [ __ ]
you didn't fail yeah but before going
worrying about what it was gonna be like
yeah because you feel like you were not
in control yeah cuz you didn't know what
to expect what to expect it's like it's
always kind of like that it's okay it's
weird because I was just thinking that
like every time before I have to do like
a radio show or something like that it's
like even though I always try to be
really prepared
it's like while I'm sitting there
waiting for them to call me like they're
waiting for Skype and stuff like that
I'm always magining I'm always like
imagine it's like what
they asked me this and I don't like
remember the answer the question I'm
just going to be sitting there going
home and like this is the kind of stuff
but then once I start talking it yeah
it's just a show like any other show
they don't ask anything out of the blue
usually and then I have to like thanks
to myself it's like well how many people
could possibly be listening to this
well you don't remember you know if you
don't they ask you a question you don't
remember you have to just say well I
don't really remember this a long time
ago right a lot of stuff I mean that's
the truth
yeah yeah that is I can't grab all that
I keep a lot of stuff in my brain but
not all not everything usually they ask
you generalities anyway that's true and
usually I can pivot and [ __ ] into a
like another slightly related quick yeah
but you're not gonna remember dates on
which some dude disappeared you never
I'm about a book that you read do you
wrote [ __ ] you know four years ago
and I've written a bunch of one since
then we could have radio shows we just
did I think Adams saying just put up the
conspiratorial that we did with them
yeah which I don't even remember it was
a fun show well it's like that was
another one word cuz he always like
sends me a list of like all the stuff he
wants to talk about which is usually
like you know whatever the last few
weeks of our podcast topics and movies
and stuff that we reviewed and so I had
like everything so I had to like reread
on a couple things like to just get
details fresh my mind did we end up
talking about any of that no I don't
think so we talked about like a couple
things sort of Adam Adam and his boy but
then they just kind of go we just go off
on tangents and I'm just like well so
much for all that preparation Adam does
nothing but ask me crazy questions as
[ __ ] he's get me to take say Vienna mr.
co-ed like Spock cuz he [ __ ] loves it
yeah it's pretty it he knows that when
I'm on his show I just slowly get more
and more intoxicated and he starts
asking me more and more off the walk
away some of it they save for their
patrons yeah you know I can see why they
do that but it's like because we always
every time we do the show we're always
on there for at least an hour and a half
it's usually related to something that I
did on a show
yeah they want me to expound on it more
yeah and then sometimes you're like
don't even remember that yeah that's you
know I tell I think that kind of half
like I said the other day we were
recording you know the upcoming episode
that's good that's gonna go up tomorrow
unless you're a patron in which case
you've already been able to watch it
that show ended up being like almost
three and a half hours long yeah and I
did okay I think like when I was re
watching I like to edit it I'm like you
can tell I'm kind of drunk like toward
the end and I think I mispronounced like
miss named some people I think I called
Robert Wagner Richard Wagner like maybe
so sorry I don't really remember but I
think yeah I think Tom is always kind of
like always charges me and he's just
always gotta like yeah by the time you
got to Natalie Wood I was pretty trade
show I thought it's like
our show is not the show you go to if
you want like super hard hitting like
information because I messed it up just
like sometimes I don't realize it until
I gotta edit it and I'm like oh I said
the wrong name there I said something
wrong cuz I'm not really just looking at
my notes but I'm trying not to it's
entertainment yeah and I mean we're not
this isn't [ __ ] a college class yeah
I mean there's other places you can get
that information we're just kind of like
using it as a launching platform on a
platform for us to make comments on it
that's right yeah yeah and you guys
enjoy it with us and we [ __ ] make
comment on the [ __ ] other
[ __ ] did a long time ago oh
yeah so we got channels out there that I
watch that are very similar just they
just take another path
it's like young people listening to
music like Black Sabbath from the 50s
and then talking about it and reacting
to it Black Sabbath isn't from the 15th
no no 50 years ago I met Oh 50 years ago
did I say it from the 50s yeah okay I
meant like from 50 years okay 1990 70
yeah and they're tripping out and you
know on old music that was old when I
was a kid yeah and you know then those
channels get a lot of hits
well I cuz I feel like it's a little bit
of an outgrowth of that you know either
young people react to X or old people
react X
yeah I mean which a lot of people seem
to like some of them are really
entertaining like I like some of the
ones work as you know I like
food-related stuff obviously but you
know I like the ones where like people
from different countries like try candy
and stuff like that like from other
countries like talking about how we're
there and yeah what good like that
the ones that get the biggest hits in
terms of music art basically younger
black dudes listening to heavy metal
yeah and the people in the audience are
telling to listen to this song and
they're learning about heavy metal their
[ __ ] trip out
so those channels those dudes get into
that [ __ ] ya know yeah I mean [ __ ]
factors didn't listen to that back in
the day but now they're like oh yeah
yeah Tony Iommi yeah you know that's it
well that's kind of a cool thing about
the Internet is that it doesn't really
matter like how old something is anymore
because everything is kind of learning
things out there everything's out there
and it you know it's it's not like oh
that was a long time ago and that's you
don't have access to it anymore and the
old-fashioned barriers are no longer
there anybody from any generation can
get to it yeah the [ __ ] that's what I
mean is everything's a fingertips yeah
so you know yeah that's why I feel like
it was we've we've had this conversation
several times before that's why I kind
of feel like the whole notion of like a
generation gap that I think that has
largely disappeared I mean you still see
it nowadays like with boomers and like
our people our age yeah but that is like
a remnant I don't think like I've always
found because we have friends our age we
have friends much younger like you we
have we have friends that are like young
enough to be our kids yeah and I never
had a problem like relating to them they
never seem to have a problem relating to
us or anything like that because
everything is just kind of out there and
if you're into the same kind of [ __ ] it
doesn't really matter how old you are
right I mean yeah the only thing is the
only difference is the experience level
and of course the hormones well the guys
are dumb dude why'd you do that you know
I mean why'd you say no man that's not
how it works
but you know they don't hide it from you
but that's all that's like that
everybody's in the same it's like
everybody did dumb [ __ ] in their teenage
years
everybody did dumb [ __ ] in their
twenties you did I did every day that's
just part of being Chinese
you're just an idiot if that everyone is
an idiot at that age there's no shame in
it I'm not judging or anything like that
because I went through the same thing I
was also an idiot in my twenties yeah
just like everyone else was yeah so yeah
come on game on Yin you don't even know
man dude that was the dude that stole my
girlfriend had to be god damn it not
even see it yeah kind of [ __ ] you don't
well at least you were dumber than that
guy who stole the girlfriend yeah yeah
maybe he was like slightly so let's do a
little bit of like let's see a
day-in-the-life or something like that
what did you do today Thomas I was
listening to the [ __ ] The Cove it
updates you know that yeah one doctor in
England who's constantly reading off all
the stats I don't trust any of this you
need the information that they put out
because it's all based upon the data is
all based upon tests on people who
tested positive they're not testing
enough people don't know how many well I
don't I mean logistically that way yeah
it's not possible today I was too
expensive is so it's like I I think the
thing is I don't think anybody is like
trying to like deceive anybody they're
just like well this is the best [ __ ] we
can do yeah I just don't know all that
you know what I mean but nobody knows
like what the hold all they know is how
many people show up to the hospital yeah
[ __ ] sick as [ __ ] how many of them
recover yeah how many of them died which
like I said that's about all you can
hope for you don't worry about how many
cases are out there they don't know yeah
and like I said a lot of people might
get it and not and they never go to the
house and they never go to the hospital
because it never gets bad and they never
realized they have there's the only
thing that they can look at is you know
anything that they know is how many
people went to we're sick enough to go
to the hospital and how many of them
died and how many of them lived most of
them who get sick enough to go to the
hospital live yeah all right so it's
it's a science called number magic you
know I don't believe in numbers it's
just magic it's magical [ __ ] you can't
get averages off of unknowns
yeah so really all you can do is just
say well out of the people that go to
the hospital this is the percentage that
live and this is the percentage that die
kind of what they're looking at is out
of the percentage of the people that go
to the hospital
looks like about what 15 percent of them
died that's still pretty good yeah
because there's a whole [ __ ] ton more
people that didn't go to the hospital
well yeah that's what I mean you're just
saying like the very very worst you're
just seeing the ones that went to the
hospital right and most people catch
this and don't even know it yeah so like
I said I'm honestly I'm less worried
about the virus itself as like you know
the economic impact like how that's
gonna be in like you know how that's
gonna affect like you know how much
money I'm gonna make and all this other
kind of stuff it's like you know am I
gonna be able to pay my bills am I gonna
the other so I'm not worried about that
either horribly but it's like that is
actually a more pressing concern for me
than the illness itself just because I
you know have the privilege of being
healthy and I you know work at home
anyway so I don't have to go out and
like deal with people so it's probably
very unlikely that I would contract it
anyways so yeah I'm kind of more worried
about money yeah that fatality number
changes you know with each country at
all they all compute it in different
ways to try to make it look better or
worse if all the top of my head it
looked like to me I think is about 15%
of them to go the hospital die yeah
that's when the plague is [ __ ]
hitting hard you know what I mean when
the that's that was kind of like what
the number would have been like in
whoo-ha yeah yeah I mean when went with
a totally packed medical system who
can't treat me very many people anymore
because it's [ __ ] filled look like
about 15% but we don't know how many
didn't go yeah that still might only be
3% that's what I mean so right you so
you can't really get like a you know an
accurate assessment because you don't
know like oh no I mean I've had a pool
is right you're right so you know like I
said no one's being deceptive it's just
that they don't they have incomplete
information and they're trying to give
you the best information that they have
so you know that's all you can do um
yeah my day I can I got up really early
went for my walk weeds like I
I've been working on recording and
editing some short stories for the
witching hour show which is coming up
this week so you know that'll be up on
Thursday if you guys don't like to
listen to that and getting some [ __ ]
ready for the next episode of the
podcast cuz I like to like keep [ __ ]
ahead of everything
also for some reason today cuz you know
like I said I'm gonna start doing like
book recommendations and [ __ ] like that
for some reason today I was like you
know I am gonna like recommend some
Edward Gorey cuz I don't know maybe like
a lot of I think a lot of older guys
like know about him and stuff like that
but I think a lot of younger people
maybe don't cuz I mean he died in 2000
um I kind of got into him he's more an
illustrator but he writes he wrote
little books too like a lot it was like
weird poems and like this kind of like
weird surrealist kind of [ __ ] that he
always had yeah back in the day back in
the 90s goth girls tend to have this
every gory stuff around their house ya
know pictures and posters and kind of
had these he had a motif that kinda
looked like something out of The Addams
Family yeah a little bit like I mean
Charles Addams his stuff was a little
more like cartoony a little more like
comic strip looking slightly whereas
eppard Gauri's was like really his is
very like Victorian Edwardian looking at
it was like this really really intricate
pen work that was like these little too
like little patterns and like little
yeah buzzes and stuff the average guy
though he hasn't seen the real Addams
Family comic strip yeah he would just
see every gory stuff though yeah kind of
dad his family yeah it's similar in that
way like in the sense that it's kind of
like McCobb and Zach but I feel like
every gory was like always such a
fascinating dude to me he was code alter
he did he were like this big hood coat
and he would go to the ballet I think um
I read this boy this book like called
it's um all the interviews with him or
Blake most of the interviews with him
see is called ascending peculiarity and
it's all interviews with him see little
drawings that he does yeah like and I
have a bunch of well I have a bunch
other stuff want to show to you but um
but yeah he's he was one of those guys
who he was like super super eccentric
but not like in a
weird like insufferable kind of way he
was just like a weird dude and that was
just Edward Gorey he's a big beard he
had this big coat he went to the ballet
every single day
like he loved the ballet and he was like
I think he lived on Cape Cod and he just
lived with a bunch of cats you know
because he loved cats so he was just
like this really weird eccentric dude
and he did all this kind of cool [ __ ] I
don't have it like right here it's back
there on the shelf but I have like a box
set because in 1977 he did all the stage
product they did like a stage production
of Dracula and he did all the sets like
all their backgrounds and stuff like
that and it is really really cool so I
have like this little thing that you can
build like out of like chipboard or like
heavy paper or whatever that looks like
the sets that he built for Dracula like
it's a 3d type like you know whatever
that you can make and it's really really
cool but yeah I kind of I first got into
him because you know back in the 70s
remember that PBS show mystery and I
think that was probably the first time I
had seen his artwork like you drew the
intro like animation for it but I think
when I was a kid the first time that I
ever saw his art like his illustrations
like big-time was in the John bel airs
book the house with a clock in its walls
you know there were really yeah because
like I don't have like this this is not
his illustration because this is like a
you know a trilogy like it has all three
of them in there but inside it does have
his illustrations for that does because
I remember I remember does a kid it was
kind of creepy looking yeah he did like
all kind of like creepy yeah he does
like all these really creepy that might
not be some of the ones like you have to
be like kind of near the beginning there
it is yeah there's one we're definitely
him
but yeah little Louis burner belt there
yeah somber feel to it now he did they
most of his books were like pretty
little like he would just do like I said
he usually like little limericks and
stuff and like I said they were really
surrealist like a lot of them didn't
really make any sense or they were like
well they're like word games or word
puzzles or two like I said he was a
surrealist so sometimes like it probably
the most famous one nowadays is the
ghastly chrome Chinese which is like the
alphabetical poem about all the
kids and how they died like I even have
like a big poster of that and that's
probably one of my favorite things yeah
to tell you guys the truth I didn't get
most of his humor I really like it I
mean the drawings I liked him
yeah but his humor was just so weird
that I was just like what the [ __ ] he
[Laughter]
talking to me it's like like surrealism
Oscar Wilde [ __ ] well not really
Oscar Wilde that was a different she's a
Brainiac she knows different yeah so to
me it's all just kind of like but it is
not and he even says that he wanted it
to be nonsense because that's what he
was into but since most of his books are
really small and like some of like when
he died they found like a whole bunch of
unpublish it like so they've they're
still like um you know doing several
published things like in little hardback
books and stuff but these are really
good like most of the like this one is
called ANFO gory and that has like his
first 15 books in it I believe and then
he also did an fo gory to which I have
also a whole bunch more in there and
this is an fitori also now there's one
more that I think came out in 2006 that
was maybe some unpublished out for some
rare stuff but I don't have that one yet
unfortunately but um all of them are
cool like probably my favorite little
books of his are the beastly baby which
is about this horrible baby that like
everyone hates and they're always trying
to like leave in places like they're
trying to leave him and like in the
bottom of a restaurant or they're trying
to like leave little dives or and I'm so
killed self and also the kids eat some
more and it's like that's probably my
favorite and then there's one called the
loathsome couple about these two
criminals you know they're pets that
one's pretty funny but like they're all
good like some of them are weirder than
others because like some of them
obviously don't even have a narrative
some of them do kind of have a narrative
but they're still kind of like these
weird unsettling stories of like little
morality plays and stuff like that cuz
he was really into like just creepy like
Victorian type of [ __ ] that was like and
he wrote like all under all these like
weird pseudonyms that were all like
anagrams of his name or you know like
versions of his name and stuff like that
so he would do like all kind of weird
[ __ ] like that I've noticed that his
fans are mostly female I think I don't
know there's just something about that
kind of humor it appeals to young women
I don't even know if I call it humor
it's just it's it's funny like some of
them are funny it's just some kind of
weird for me entertainment but there
yeah there I mean there's nobody like
him really there never was and I don't
think there ever will be closest thing I
would price closest person to him I
would think that it ever existed or
dolly
that's another dudes kind of absurdist
yeah you know yeah because you're I mean
you're just kind of like trying to make
a a point that like nothing really makes
sense so like why the [ __ ] should I even
try making sense and I feel like that's
kind of what Edward Gorey that's where
he was coming from and it's really weird
to me and kind of awesome that somebody
is eccentric as him is so well known
still you know what I mean because
usually someone with with his very
specific kind of vision and this very
specific weird kind of like surrealist
humor that he had that usually doesn't
translate to a wide audience but for
whatever reason his stuff just kind of
seemed to strike a chord with a lot of
people I've even been I went to you uh
this is probably a while back but I'd
say art museum here in Orlando I think
this is probably maybe like eight or
nine years ago they had an Edward Gorey
exhibit and so I actually went there and
like you know I bought some stuff I got
a t-shirt I got all kind of [ __ ] but
yeah I've got all kind of Edward Gorey
stuff like other than that I've got like
little postcards and shirts and stuff
like that because I just I just always
loved that aesthetic I was immediately
as soon as I read that John Bel Air's
book I was like immediately taken by
that style and then when I found out
that he wrote his own books and he had
like all these weird little poems and
stuff I got super super into it but yeah
I actually can't refer to Salvador Dali
then it was just in your face just
[ __ ] absurdism yeah he was a bastard
yeah I've been through the Dali Museum
in st. Petersburg too like when I lived
over there he did some weird films where
he's out on play people out on platforms
playing piano he was on play he was
playing a piano in the ocean one I think
so if I remember
[ __ ] waves crashing over him well his
most famous one was in shin and aloo
Andalusian dog that one was like the
ants coming out of the hand and like the
sliced eyeball and that was him crazy
[ __ ] and and Ben well those two made
that one water one side of a mustache
because he didn't need the other side
because he just told me and he did some
cool [ __ ] like when I went to the Dali
Museum in st. Petersburg like I said
it's probably like 12 13 15 years ago
something like that um he did some
amazing [ __ ] like he had this like
really cool like these really weird like
chess sets that he made um I think the
most impressive thing for me was seeing
the temptation of st. Anthony in person
I did not realize how [ __ ] ginormous
painting is it was really really big it
was it's just got well it's kind of hard
to describe but there was a you know you
can google it all right but yeah it was
I didn't realize that it was that large
so it was like I was like what LSD had
have been involved
oh I'm sure most things yes LSD was
involved all right so you want to wrap
up the Monday show yes it's alright
we're gonna wrap it up for Monday so be
safe and we'll talk to you again
tomorrow